and the idea is that uh when you have a
neural network which has any py Define
nonlinearity so it can be railu can be
leaky railu can be Sawtooth as well like
anything that's piecewise and linear so
if you have a neural network like that
with such nonlinearities then what it
basically does is it cuts up the input
space uh into linear regions and then
linearly Maps each region to the output
so basically that's what the theory says
that you have this spine where the
neural network boundaries are like where
the spline boundaries are defined by the
network weights and the mapping is also
defined by the network weights so what
we've been doing is we've been studying
uh neural networks uh generative model
generators VA encoders like any neural
network with such nonlinearities from
this plent perspective so recently uh
we've had a couple of papers where what
we do is uh like since for a generative
model that's been framed uh suppose on
ffq you know how uh like the a pre-train
model basically uh linearly like cuts it
up into linear regions and then Maps
each linear regions so looking at the
which we can find out how this mapping
works we can General